I mean what's most appealing to me is
Edgar's company okay what what was it
called the benchmade market the sofa
company the sofa is made yeah at least
that makes the couches yeah he said oh
just because I think they're I think one
of the things he communicated so clearly
was their distinct competitive advantage
ah very good when he goes in I'm you
know so even let's say I do a little bit
of research on the space and there's a
couple other furniture companies you
know competing and thinking about open
up kiosks one of the things I would do
if we were going in doing diligence so I
look at the space and I sit down and I'm
like alright tell me about these other
guys and what are they doing that's
different than you and what why are you
unfairly suited to do this and I got the
sense remember that that's what I would
get a very confident response back from
him I have these talents this is what's
different about our manufacturing
process is how long it takes to figure
this [ __ ] out nobody else can do it and
here's why I'm gonna win and that's what
I want to hear you know the the very
best entrepreneurs just have
unreasonable expectations of themselves
they know their success is inevitable
and they're not there to kind of sell
you and convince you they just know it's
gonna work
yeah and I think sometimes that gets
caught up in language but other times
it's just not there and if I can't feel
that or see that or hear it it's like an
inevitability yeah I mean Kevin Systrom
when you talked to him in the early days
when he's one person sitting in peer 28
you know you're like he'll be like so
when we get to 50 million users then
we'll turn on this other feature there's
like do you know how have you noticed
you're the only one coding you know like
it's just an inevitability in that you
know Travis people always ask Travis you
know did you guys know back then Travis
is gonna up and the entire world
transportation system really yeah yeah
pretty much there's just there was no
doubt about that yeah and his voice and
so so that's something I'm looking for
when I see a company where they say we
have a distinct technological advantage
of sitting product manufacturing
advantage to design advantage whatever
that's that's something you can start to
build an investment thesis around